i want to get right into it what's what
let's just jump right into it
around the box yeah yeah i gotta i'm
just excited to talk about this
can you explain uh what the the [ __ ] of
the round table is
right away please get it out
[Music]
so i saw this thing i advertised online
and it was just like this giant fleshy
it's it's this
fleshy giant roll of a bunch of cookies
there's no there's no other way to
describe it it's it's just like the
dough
and you bought it for a video to clarify
yeah yeah one of my videos
where i'm just like sex products in
japan that are animely weird
and it's just like just a bunch of
[ __ ] of like girls six right
six of them around and you're supposed
to like take it with the boys when you
want to have a little party
invite the boys over for let's let's
have a nice little little
[ __ ] i remember you told me something
about it that was like it's in
order of age yeah one of them's like oh
you know because it's japan you know
okay elementary middle school high
school
adult how how far adult do we go
grandma yeah grandma puss
at the end it's like one of them just
sagging down yeah
it's just like just like a gaping hole
so that's a great first topic i just
wanted to talk about that
i never thought of that i never thought
to myself i need like an item
for this circle jerk something's missing
from this circle joke oh yeah
the thing is like i've we've always
known about japan japan has like some
weird ass
toys everyone right everyone knows but
like having moved here and really like
you know
living with sydney and seeing some of
the [ __ ] she has to buy for her channel
it's just like i
i thought yeah gunpoint
like what's the other route i thought my
faith in humanity couldn't get lower the
next week it just like lowers every
single week because i remember
remember this one time we were in this
like dojinshi shop and she was like
looking for
weird things to buy and then we just see
this brain right
and i'm just like why are they selling a
brain there's there's no reason why you
a shop should be selling a brain and
then and then we pick up the box and we
turn it over
and it's just like this brain that you
can [ __ ] like stick your dick in
so it's it's a literal fleshlight that's
shaped like a brain
some people want a brain fog some people
want a literal brain
so heavy what worries me what worries me
about the
the round table of the you know object
um is that normally if i wanted to [ __ ]
a brain
i'd probably do that in private i'm
probably gonna keep that to myself
but there's someone out there who has
six homies who's like boys
i've got it and then they're all equally
[ __ ] up and they've all told each
other
like how would you even position
yourself there's actually a diagram
that comes with the box of like they're
so so like this there's an anal hole
like right at the bottom
as well it's like imagine this like huge
play-doh of like
like with six [ __ ] on this player
stool right yeah yeah it looks like a
bar store
and then there's a hole at the bottom so
how it goes is that there's a guy at the
bottom
and you put it you put it on a dick and
then like six other dicks can be [ __ ]
this this [ __ ] hole
as it's just on this guy how is this
episode of already more loot than the
shibuya
episode your parents are gonna be
watching this